hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamra Dessau and today I
didn't want to comb out my hair so I'm
wearing a wig and I saw a violation
Wendy could you not ruin everything
no look I love sci-fi so much and I grew
up with sci-fi grew up with Star Trek
and Star Wars and bad sci-fi films on
the sci-fi channel that I can't even
remember the names - I have been looking
forward to this film for awhile I didn't
read the books and like most civilized
people
the worst people I like to read the
books before see the films for this I
did not and and I was feeling like a
little weird about that but honestly I'm
so glad I went into this knowing nothing
and surprised that even going into it
knowing nothing it delivered so well on
so many levels especially story-wise it
was so good I'm not gonna give major
spoilers for the end of the movie but I
am going to give light spoilers so just
be aware of that I just don't feel like
I've had to leeteuk about the film
unless I give a little bit away the
story is about Natalie Portman's
character who is a biologist and her
husband
Oscar puts his name Oscar Oscar Isaac is
a soldier of some kind and he goes into
what is called the shimmer one day he
shows up after presumably being dead for
about a year and she goes looking for
answers after he becomes extremely ill
she finds out about the shimmer she goes
into it because she herself is a very
smart and well-known biologist and
soldier which is amazing she's such a
badass and then she finds out what is
happening in the shimmer kind of there's
a lot happening in the shimmer let me
tell you there's a lot of play with
different times in the film you go from
the future at the very open and you kind
of slice in between the future and the
present and the past throughout the film
which I always really enjoy if they're
clear and concise with it which they
totally are in this do you just spend
the entire time watching this film
filled with questions which is so
exciting so you don't I
never felt like I mean I never can call
anything in film I never know what's
going to happen but I I never in this
film was like oh this is obviously gonna
happen Oh like it was very suspenseful
and very mysterious which was super fun
it's got this really high budget feel
which is kind of weird for sci-fi
honestly the Syfy I'm used to but is it
feels like it's like damn this is sci-fi
like the root of it feels very sci-fi
very fun like very much what I wanted to
see and it's like we started at Trog
sci-fi and now we're here damn it's an
exciting time to be alive the cast is
also incredible I'm always such a fan of
Natalie Portman she's been a part of
some things that I really loved I loved
Black Swan I loved her the Star Wars
prequels I know that they're terrible
they hold a special place in my heart
because saw them at a young age and I
loved her in them I think she's
wonderful
I just always find her so truthful she's
very raw in what she does whenever she's
given a crime scene which she usually is
cuz she's really good at crying in films
it seems like she's really crying you
seems real she's a good actress and so
she had a few witness and they were all
phenomenal I did hear that in the second
book the character that she's playing is
Asian
I guess this film is based off of the
first book and in the first book they
don't talk about race at all for
characters which is okay all right fine
new poll
there's no Asian women in film though so
it's kind of a bummer that it didn't go
to who it should have gone to but I do
really think that Natalie is incredible
and I I love her she did an interview
about that subject and it was really
nice so um finds that if you can if
you're interested Tessa Thompson is also
in this and I love her I recently just
saw her in thor ragnarok
and she was amazing she just
continuously is doing great things she
was wonderful in this my only gripe
really with the film at all is that I
really wish
at the side-characters the women that
she goes into the shimmer with got to be
developed a bit more you get to really
know her and her husband and their
characters and you feel for them you
feel a little less for the characters
that go into the shimmer with her before
other women and I really wish you got to
know them I feel that in the book I'm
sure you did get to know them it's
really cool thing it's the film is like
all women it's awesome I really really
enjoyed that like scientist women like
smart ass women like that's cool as hell
but I wish you got to know them a little
bit better if I knew more about Tessa
Thompson's character I think that
would've been cooler and then spoiler
when they pass away when they die you
would feel more for that too I feel like
that was a little bit of a missed
opportunity I don't I don't know what
they would have done to make that better
I don't know anything but I feel like
that I could have been improved upon a
bit a lot of scary things happen when
they enter the shimmer the shimmer is if
you haven't seen the trailer you don't
know where it is the shimmer is like
this crazy kind of force field
it seems around this kind of just patch
of Earth and you walk into it and a lot
of crazy things were happening within it
a lot of mutations with plants and
animals a lot of lost time which was I
think for me the scariest part there's a
moment where when they first entered
they lose a lot of time and that's such
a scary thing to wake up disoriented and
then to be like I've been out for days
and then once they're inside it's a
group of five women and they're faced
with a lot of trials to get to the
lighthouse which is where the shimmer
initially started and started growing
from there I wrote this is one of the
most compelling stories I've seen in
such a long time I feel like the
marketing for this could have been so
much better I feel like Pacific Rim 2 is
getting so much more marketing and maybe
it's just my personal preference but I
don't care at all about Pacific Rim 2
and I care so much about this the first
time I saw this trailer I was like super
engaged immediately and I didn't see
another trailer until like yesterday
right before it came out today and I
just that didn't make a ton of sense to
me there's also a lot of science that
here like these are all scientists who
go into the shimmer and they're saying a
lot of scientific terms and you're like
I don't know if that's real it probably
isn't it's a sci-fi film but I love when
movies do that and you you believe it or
you like Allah suspend your disbelief
for a while because it's not like
unbelievable it's not out of the realm
of belief it's not like a sharknado it's
like they're saying things and you're
like probably in real life not real but
like I super believe it here that's how
I felt in the Martian when um Matt Damon
that is i whoever that is I really
believed all of the things he was doing
in space I really believe that he was
growing plants in space and making
fertilizer in space I really believed it
and it wasn't true and it wasn't real
but I believed it and I love when movies
can do that the Martian Matt Damon good
job Cameron you know who people are so
at the end everyone who she went in with
are not with her anymore and she walks
into the lighthouse which she's made it
to and she leaves her backpack this is
the other thing that really bothered me
she leaves her backpack before going in
and I know she's probably thinking like
I'm probably just not gonna make it out
of this lighthouse and like I don't need
this extra 30 pounds of weight to tweed
out but that just really bothered me
you're not gonna bring all of your
supplies like what if you have another
like lapse in time and then you don't up
you have no food like what don't don't
do that
don't leave your things that always
bothers me when people don't have
supplies like that's such an easy thing
you already had that why let them go the
whole time I was super engaged and there
wasn't any point that disappointed me
though the end is very indescribable
like I feel like even if I really wanted
to hard spoil it I couldn't cuz it's
very odd and it set up a second film
which is exciting because I definitely
wanted more from it and I don't feel
like I left it feeling like gypped like
they didn't finish it out well but I do
feel like there's so much more to tell
and I want to know it I want to read the
book so badly I feel like I would get so
much more out of them I love when you
see a movie it's so good but you still
feel like the books would give you even
more detail and information I yes
yep yep I would absolutely recommend
seeing this film and also seeing in
theaters so impactful
I was recently showing a bunch of people
the hereditary trailer which i think is
so good and I had seen it for the first
time in theaters and then I was like
just we be talking it up to friends and
then I showed them and we watched it on
a small computer monitor and I was like
oh it wasn't a scary and cool and
impactful as it was when I saw it in
theatres I still think it looks good but
not nearly as good this is one of those
films where it's like yeah this is like
it's impactful and I think that the big
screen really does that for you I had
such a good time with it
Natalie gives another amazing
performance and I continue to love her
and I love the mostly female cast and I
love that they're breaking a lot of
stereotypes in this and I love that it's
just really good eerie sci-fi I think
that's super cool I'm all for it
I also can't wait to talk about the
Oscars and I'm gonna give my picks for
the Oscars coming up in a few weeks so
keep watching thank you so much for
tuning in this week I'll see y'all soon
bye
you
[Music]